qu'il a enterré la gauche aussi de me
strauss kahn fait c'était le compte
rendu qu'en faisait la journaliste de
logroño des terres sur son propre
enterrement parce que je ne pense pas
que ça le rend particulièrement
populaire
je sens quand même la blessure d gohelle
et là il ya aussi des images qui tue le
jour où on accuse le président de la
république de mépriser le peuple et
c'est à ce colloque on voit on voit
dominique strauss kahn partir en
limousine avec chauffeur et après nous
en braille des valeurs de la gauche je
parle encore une fois du visuel c'est je
pense qu'il est assez mal placé
notamment vis-à-vis des catégories
populaires pour donner des leçons
je dirais de d'amour des cas des classes
populaires
donc les valeurs de gauche et en plus
franchement moi j'ai relu 10 fois cette
phrase on parle de la pensée complexe du
président mais là elle est ce que vous
êtes sûr d'avoir bien compris
moi je les relance mois vont pas très
bien comprendre la pensée complexe de
dominique strauss kahn entre la
dialectique n'équilibre la vie ensemble
à la limite des modèles macro aurait pu
dire ça aussi en fait dans la campagne
menée par lh2 est un droit d'auteur
donc je crois que ça va disparaître très
vite ça va être très vite emporté dans
bach à la clinique